hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome back to my channel and today
right now i want to give you a thorough
up-to-date understanding of what's going
on in the property market
so there's been loads of changes and it
can be really confusing hearing about
the stamp duty holiday
is it ending what's happening so i want
to give you an up-to-date of exactly
what's happening
with the stamp duty holiday how that
affects you how that affects property
investors
also massively is the tenant eviction
ban
the tenant eviction ban has been
something i've talked about a lot i'm
gonna be giving an
update on what's happening with that
right now so again
massive for property investors next some
of the large
institutions that are investing in
uk residential property right now and
how this could be a game changer and how
this affects you
and then finally what house prices are
doing so what property prices are at
right now
what they're doing what's happened so if
you're a property investor you kind of
need to watch this video
and if you appreciate me taking the time
to do all this research
and communicate it with you in hopefully
an articulate concise way
then just let me know by hitting the
like button so do that hit the like
button what are you messing around for
you're watching the video
hit the like button do it right now also
please subscribe turn the notification
bell on
that would be amazing and share the
video around with your property friends
do that and do that right now
and then i'm gonna hit you with the
content first tenant eviction ban
the tenant eviction ban you probably
have heard about this and know what it
is
but it just means that you can't evict
tenants and they did this throughout
lockdown there was a lot of
there was two camps some people were
saying that the tenant eviction ban was
great
because if you're a tenant and you're
locked down and you're losing your job
potentially
the last thing you want is to be kicked
out and evicted during lockdown so some
people were saying
isn't the tenant eviction ban wonderful
then there was people on the other hand
like me
that were saying actually the tentative
man's terrible because if you've got a
tenant
who's not paying rent you have to get
rid of them
because why should a landlord just go
all right no problem
sainsbury's don't go oh you can just
have free food
it's all right so why should a landlord
just go you can have free rent
so i didn't think it was right now the
good news
is that the tenant eviction ban has
officially
ended so it ended um i think may the
29th
last week so it's not ended so you can
now evict tenants
listen man if you're a property investor
have a heart be decent don't
bang your tenant out as quick as you can
if they've got unfortunate circumstances
if you're a good person karma will come
around and good things will happen
you'll reap what you sow
also just because tenant eviction bans
ended there's a big backlog of court
cases right now so it's not super easy
to evict a tenant as easy as it was in
2019. you can evict them
but it's not quite as easy as it was um
also there's there's something called
breathing space legislation which says
that if you're if you're a debtor
the creditor the person that is owed the
money um
like the desert can say hold on i want
60 today's breathing space that's
like a thing that's in right now and
some tenants are jumping on this
so you can evict tenants it's a little
bit slow than it was however
generally speaking i think that's fair i
finally think that's fair
that's a good set up and i'm really
pleased as we're coming out of um
lockdown the tenant eviction band has
ended so that's the first thing although
if you enjoy the video if you find it
helpful
hit like drop a comment and share the
video subscribe
next some of the large institutional
players
that are coming and investing in
residential property residential meaning
it's a home right it's not commercial so
the financial times reported
that lloyd's bank lloyd's bank
are now buying got properties and
renting them out
lloyd's bank are potentially going to be
one of the biggest landlords
in the uk the crazy thing about that
is lloyd's bank how do they invest money
how do they do it
they invest money by telling you
to save your money and put it in the
bank
safely and then they invest your money
check it out lloyd's bank you go to
lloyd's bank and you say can i have a
bank loan please
for 50 000 pounds because i want to
invest in property they'll tell you it's
too risky
that's risky says lloyd's bank they'll
keep your money
and then they'll invest it in property
you go to the lloyd's bank and say i
want fifty thousand pounds to get
married
they know that that money will be
squandered and gone they'll give it to
you
and they'll keep you in debt as a slave
so it's kind of crazy
and there's some there's some real big
developers now there's some
big movers to shake as lord banker one
example coming into the uk or maybe
they're in the uk already but
buying up homes to rent out what
i think that is going to potentially
push prices up and
talking of house prices which is the
next category it house prices over the
last 12 months
have gone up by according to nationwide
bank have gone up by 10.9
nationwide that's a lot that's a lot
in the last year considering what's been
happening so
if you look back at my videos from june
july time or if you look at my instagram
posts and my tweets
i was saying in june july time that
house prices were going to go up by at
least 10
in the next 12 months it's happened and
at the time everyone was saying
well we'll check back in a year well
it's been a year now i was right
where are all the other educators right
now there's so many educators on youtube
doing videos and stuff just because the
market's booming right now
there's a bit more stability i've been
here from the beginning
i've been here from i've i've been doing
videos on youtube every day for years
for seven years i've been on youtube
after six or seven years
i think six may be coming up to seven so
you know be careful who you listen to
because even the media people on youtube
people that write blogs
they've proven themselves wrong again
and again and again now i haven't got a
crystal ball
but hey i'll let my results speak i'll
let my track record speak
stammy holiday is being phased out right
now
jump on the bandwagon of buying property
okay stamp duty holiday they're phasing
it out from the 30th of june
until the end of september stampede
holiday applies
up into a 250 000 pound purchase so
it's gonna be phased out they are still
encouraging people to buy property right
now they're still encouraging people to
buy property you know what happened
though it's really interesting
so in april 2020 i had properties for
sale on auction
okay and it was terrible everything got
paused
valuers couldn't go to houses you
couldn't view properties there was over
half a million properties
that were just paused you know and and
it looked like the market was going to
crash and everything was crashing and
everything was going crazy
and what they did was they the
government brought in incentives and
they tried to keep the property market
kind of stable but it didn't stay stable
it actually
it actually it actually blew up so
what's going to happen in the future
with property
and i'll always say every area has its
own
economy rents have gone down in london
and they've gone up
in birmingham so you can't just have a
simple
house prices across the board are
expected to do this because it might be
that house prices have gone up by 10.9
across the acros across the country but
some people have bought in the wrong
areas
it's gone down and some people have
bought in the right areas has gone up by
20
so you want to make sure that you're
buying in a trending area you want to
make sure that you're buying
a good price where the property is going
to cash flow positive so it's really
important that you do this right
i'd like to listen i've just rattled on
this all this information
over the last few minutes in one take
it's just it's just
it's simple it's easy i want to be going
on some more advanced strategies
i want to teach you how to find the
right areas how to crunch the deal
how to negotiate the deal so if you want
to join me at the property investors
crash course in other big news
i'm doing a tour across england i'm
going to be in swindon i'm going to be
in
portsmouth i'm going to be london london
sold out okay people are messaging me
all the time london sold out when's the
next one in london
just drive to birmingham it's a couple
hours you know if you're gonna be
stopped at the first hurdle
then you're gonna be stopped in this
business so get down to the property
investors crash course whether you're at
manchester whether you're in leeds
before it completely sells out i'm gonna
be doing a tour between june 21st
and the very end of june i'd love to
meet you in person i'll personally be
there
i'll leave a link in the description get
booked on get educated
educate yourself invest in yourself
before investing in property
do it right and become financially free
i can't wait to work with you
you can get a free ticket to the
property investors crash course up here
okay so again just do it just
get booked on i'll see you there it's
free
subscribe to the channel right over here
and thanks so much for watching
i will see you at the property investors
crash course real soon
you